Ronda santis looking really really good
over the weekend as he evacuates more
Americans from the Holy Land as War
breaks out happy to report we had
another flight bringing Floridians back
from Israel land in the we hours of the
morning we've been able to help hundreds
of people get back uh from the war zone
safely to the United States to the State
of Florida uh We've also put a lot of
supplies that have been donated over to
Israel and I know they're really
appreciative of it and we've got another
flight coming most likely tomorrow
morning so federal government dragged
its feet a lot of those folks didn't
have any options we stepped up showed
the leadership and are delivering
results this is the best thing Dan
santis can do for his campaign because
it's also the thing that's going to give
him a path if this primary doesn't go
his way the thing that Ronda santis can
do is get results from his political
office Donald Trump does not currently
have a political office Ronda santis
does